We are all family.
We are all brothers and sisters.
I’m not getting all new-agey on you, I seriously
mean that.
Hello distant relatives, Julian here for DNews.
Have you ever wondered just how related you
are to a random stranger?
Probably not, but today we’re going to answer
that question anyway.
Genetic diversity is increased in organisms
that reproduce sexually because we combine
half our genes with half of someone else’s
to get a new mix.
DNA also changes a little from parents to
offspring because when they’re forming,
sperm and eggs randomly swap genetic code
between the pairs of chromosomes two or three
times, and then take half of the new, unique
chromosomes.
Obviously how genetically similar you are
to the people you pass on the street has a
lot to do with where you are.
If you live in an area that’s has a lot
of people from diverse backgrounds, or if
you live somewhere far away from where you
grew up, you’re going to have more genetic
drift than if you live somewhere like Iceland.
Iceland has a population of only 320,000 and
two thirds of those people live in or around
the capital of Reykjavik.
They’re descendants of Norse and Celtic
settlers from 1,200 years ago, and there hasn’t
been a lot of new blood since then.
The odds that two Icelandic people are distant
cousins is pretty high; high enough that thousands
of Icelanders use an app to make sure they’re
not Björking someone they’re going to see
at a family reunion later.
Sometimes you may share more DNA with someone
because you had an ancestor who was… let’s
just say “prolific” because it sounds
more scientific than “bang-tastic.”
Famously about 10% of men living today in
lands the Mongol empire once claimed have
the Y chromosome of none other than Genghis
Khan.
That translates to 16 million men with the
same Y chromosome.
Seriously, the Mongol empire was huge.
But what about total random strangers from
different parts of the world?
Surely you’re much different than them,
right?
Maybe not, because a 2007 study published
in Genetics compared a group of europeans
to sub saharan africans, and found pairs of
random people from each population were more
genetically similar than pairs of people within
their population a fifth of the time.
So what’s the total difference between you
and a totally random person on the other side
of the world?
I’ll put it to you like this: If you have
a brother or sister you are 99.95% genetically
identical.
So how much DNA do you think you have in common
with a stranger?
Nope, you’re wrong.
You are at least 99.9% identical to anyone.
Anyone at all.
That weird guy on the bus, Kevin Bacon, me.
Almost all your cells have about 6 billion
base pairs that make up the genetic code that
is expressed as you, meaning 5,994,000,000
[5 billion, 9 hundred and 94 million] of them
are the same as anyone else.
Mind.
Blown.
Even though we’re all so similar, it’s
still a good idea to mix up the gene pool
and date outside the family tree.
Laci explains why down here.
So how does this information affect how you
think about other people?
Let us know in the comments or find us on
facebook and twitter, don’t forget to subscribe,
and I’ll see you next time on DNews.